is another way to avoid image files and
to keep your site responsive if you need
to use a graphical symbol like an arrow
a star or a heart check whether it's
available as a character in a font you
might be surprised what's available when
symbols and icons are achieved using
fonts they have all the responsive
advantages of text they're infinitely
scalable amenable to text CSS effects
and don't incur an extra download the
graphics on this page are built without
image files the body has a CSS gradient
and the star is just a text character
with a CSS shadow applied all
responsively sized the unicode standard
defines the universal character set over
100,000 characters have been defined so
far and some fonts support many
thousands of these get to know your
glyphs